reality hey reality what a concept let's
do this all right
countdown five four three two one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are sitting down with dr. Garrett
Lisi what's up yeah thank you having me
on the show thanks for coming on the
show greatly appreciate it so we're
gonna be talking about physics what are
you talking about reality we're talking
about the subatomic level of reality
this is gonna be very exciting stuff
I'm pumped oh cool I spend too much my
time living there so I'm happy to back
and try make it as relatable as possible
as well but that's definitely something
that we care about here is making
complex subjects relatable and see your
background you had PhD in physics in
university california san diego and then
19 years at Pacific Science Institute
well it was just an idea for most of
those 19 years but now it's reality
which is great I'm excited to showcase
some of the the content that we have
lined up for for highlighting psi and
what would you what would you even call
psi it's mostly right now it's mostly a
house with delusions of grandeur but
what I'd like to build it into is a
larger residential science institute in
science retreat the same way you have
retreats for artists or writers there
isn't really a equivalent sort of space
that scientists can go through to to
work on their stuff and so that's really
what I'm trying to build in psi it's
just a nice place and a beautiful
location where scientists can come out
and spend time working on whatever they
want and enjoying the environment and
what better place to do it then in
freaking Maui yeah yeah I haven't found
any place I'd like better in the world
so yeah yeah so you got a nice property
with a couple cabins on it
enabling scientists to come and retreat
and work on their research and in
beautiful Hawaii 20-minute drive from
the ocean
up on the volcano fifteen and sixteen
hundred feet up sounds so great we'll
showcase some of this content soon okay
so let's let's start with this so we
have this I always like to explain it
this way humans are kind of right the
sandwiched between the macroscopic
galactic perspective as well as the
micro subatomic perspective we're like
sandwich yes you look at the you know
scales of levels of magnitude between
subatomic particles all the way up to
the scale of our observable universe
humans are about in the middle as far as
the size of things go yeah so
interesting how that happened so okay so
when we experience life we're
experiencing life on this let's just
call it on this level of like meters
because things are kind of metric right
in terms of meters and stuff like that
chair is about a meter you're about a
meter on the board whiteboards like
three meters so it's kind of like I met
yeah metric in the sense the meter was
invented because it's on the human scale
yeah yeah exactly it's it's not a it's
not a natural unit of measure it's one
that we made up because it's convenient
for us to use as humans because we're
about on that same scale yep yep and
then and then so then we go all the way
up to hundreds of millions and even
billions of then lightyears and yeah and
then down we go to the subatomic level
the even s lowest the Planck length well
we haven't gotten that low yet
fortunately for us space is wonderfully
transparent and we're surrounded by you
know clouds of billions of galaxies in
our universe and we can actually see
them and and collect data from them and
see how extraordinarily extraordinary
distances into space because it's
transparent yes
similarly we can use particle
accelerators you know microscopes and
then particle accelerators which are
basically larger microscopes with more
energy to see down smaller and smaller
and see how the micro world behaves and
we see
you know incredible richness on both
scales and also sort of different
emergent levels laws of physics on those
scales okay so the laws of physics that
govern our world maybe we once as we get
down to this the particle accelerator
and being able to see what goes on at
that level
let's let's start with about about 1500
or so in this renaissance area time
period we're getting optics we're
getting to see up and see down macro
micro and like you said you started
talking about microscopes so then we
started being able to see at kind of
like the bacterial level about that
level and I don't even know what that is
in terms of is that is that at the
millimeter is that at the micro
millimeter yes we're closer to micro
mean micrometer level okay so some
micrometer level that's one millionth
yeah that's one minus six yeah 10
devices so one millionth of a meter for
bacteria and then now even a bacteria is
made up of atoms and atoms are made up
of subatomic particles so now now we're
breaking down a little further so now
when did we first I guess even think
that like okay well now you know I'm
moving my hand and now I'm moving atoms
moving right I mean idea I think goes
all the way back to the Greeks where
they talked about the fundamental sort
of discrete atoms of nature so that
ideas been around for a while but it it
often takes a I mean there we have a lot
of ideas as humans about how our
universe works before we actually have
access to be able to measure at that
scale so but very often you can have
insights and how things are working what
you know what reality actually is it's
just ninety percent of the time they're
wrong but actually through science we
actually are able to examine these
scales the deeper and deeper level and
then find out that some of those ideas
were right and some of the early ideas
about atoms we're actually quite
insightful and turned out to be correct
even even Newton had a sort of an atomic
picture in his head or I think they were
called corpuscles of light and now we
call them photons but he had the idea
they should sort of come in packets
before anybody - any inkling of quantum
mechanics yeah yeah so so we think it's
sort of our job is as theoretical
physicist to think ahead of our
experiments if we can and come up with
descriptions of nature that might
actually be true that might be true and
then you get a go test and test
hypothesis so yeah it always fascinated
me seeing planets orbiting a star and
then seeing electrons orbiting the
nucleus of an atom yeah yeah yeah
similar forces at play you have the you
know the inverse-square attraction of
the gravitational force and you have a
similar inverse-square attraction of
electromagnetism between oppositely
charged things so with that you have
similar behavior that's so interesting
yeah so the positive and negative of the
atom of the electrons and the and the
protons the protons in the nucleus and
then the the gravitational pulled
between the star and the planets yeah
that's so cool and they used to I mean
back before back when we knew enough to
know that matter was atomic and to get
an idea of what atoms are I think it was
Rutherford saw the atoms have nuclei
where it went most of them most of the
mass concentrated in their center and
with the electrons orbiting it and there
is this Bohr model of the atom yep and
it was very much a planetary model where
you have the electrons orbiting the
nuclei just like you have planets
orbiting the Sun is a direct analogy
yeah but then we learned that things on
the atomic scale are actually very
different yes and this electron see you
don't orbit like planets they they exist
in a potential probability state like
different likelihoods of being at
different locations around the nuclei so
although they have angular momentum and
they you know have movement that way
they're they're fundamentally different
so quantum mechanics describes a
fundamentally different world
anytime work scale seems so really
they're not planets and also whereas
planets all have their individual
characteristics and they're abundant you
know their environment and all their own
things that make them them subatomic
particles don't appear to be like that
they they appear to be perfectly
interchangeable things so one electron
is identical to any other electron
acceptor where it is and how it's moving
yeah so there's both the earth is much
different than Mars but the third
electron and the fourth electron are
totally identical identical and then
also the the positioning of the
electrons around the atom just moves
completely differently yes in fact
quantum mechanically they don't even
have a definite position yeah it doesn't
even make sense this is super
positioning yeah there was superposition
of all their possible positions at the
same time yes but but it's still angular
momentum moving it's not just super it's
not just super positioning around that's
right yeah
okay so okay so now we get to when did
we when did we even figure out I guess
that atoms could be broken down into
further when did we figure that out and
well I mean they they figured out like
there was like alpha and beta radiation
and gamma radiation from atoms and then
they figured out that alpha radiation
was actually two protons in a Neutron
clustered together that were coming out
for radiation so there's there's not
naturally radioactive material
mm-hmm and I think it was a Curie who
did some of the pioneering work in
radiation that way and just try to
figure out what what the heck was going
on and so I don't remember when the
first breakdown was four atoms being
four nuclei being composed of protons
and neutrons but it was a it was a
wonderfully succinctly of describing
chemistry once you contrive atoms in
terms of their protons and neutrons you
get the periodic table you know that now
we have different versions of the
periodic table three more two
than the standard one you may have seen
in high school or so mm-hmm
but the different ways of portraying it
that actually are more intuitive but but
you get this this wonderful
they're like little later Lego blocks of
how they can be put together and now
through quantum mechanics we have a
really good description of how all of
those are formed so we we understand
atomic physics really well even though
if he even though it gets complicated
it's the early 1900s I think it was
around there maybe even a little bit
earlier yeah yeah yeah and then and then
we started being able to manipulate
atoms and then create fission and we saw
the results of that both in the nuclear
nuclear weapons for world war ii and in
atomic energy generation and so let's
just pause there for a second so this is
taking very large atoms yeah and this is
slowly breaking them down to lesser
atoms yeah pretty much if you if you
pile enough protons and neutrons
together into a large atom that's an
unstable state and it likes to split and
when it when it splits that it releases
energy a lot by the the pieces coming
out with more momentum and you know
we're fairly primitive well you know we
but we know that once we have something
that has a lot of energy they it's very
hot and we can you know run water past
it heat up the water and then use that
heated water to go through steam
turbines and generate electrical power
okay so so so then there's running water
and then the energy from from the atom
splitting is heating the water which is
then that heated water is powering a
turbine yeah
it's pretty funny that we go back
basically to the steam steam engine
might as well be a coal burner okay
because we're I mean it's the primitive
way is work you know so that's that's
the interesting thing is is the
technological advancement is cumulative
so when you have an advanced yeah it's
not alone its building on all the
previous advances yes and that this is
really what's so fantastic about
technological process because that that
produces an exponential
rate of increase in technology
technological progress which is which is
great
what makes it so nice to be alive right
now these things have progressed at such
a rapid rate it's it's gotten pretty
great
agreed ubiquity and so many great things
that we need also physics is building on
top of the fundamental yeah we're yeah
we build off what we know and when we
find new stuff it has to connect and and
agree with what we already have known
and established yep so okay so now we
just did a little bit on fission
hopefully we can figure out the abundant
source of fusion energy we can fuse
atoms safely for less energy that we
took to put in that we can get out then
we can have abundant energy fantastic
because you don't only have heat being
produced like you do in fission but the
the atoms involved are much lighter and
less less themselves they're not
radioactive yes so the problem with
fusion is it generates so much heat that
you can't contain it yeah so we can we
can start a fusion reaction alright and
and we can get power from it the problem
is is it heats up its container to such
a degree that will melt the container so
we have to we have to try to trap it in
a you know magnetic field look to my
neck field and that's like the Ptolemaic
tokamak yes hope tokamak yeah yeah and
and these are so and it's probably one
of the hardest engineering challenges on
the planet right now is to build a way
to contain an ignited plasma ignited
plas yeah and and to you know pull power
out of this thing this is one of our
greatest challenges right now yeah this
would be a great way to get energy
without without the same radioactive
waste to deal with yep
it's funny that all these things it's
still gonna go back to you know based on
a steam engine where you know you use
the heat the heat up water and runs
turbines yeah yeah yeah water is just
such an efficient way to transport Heat
so cuz yeah water has a very high heat
capacity you can hold a lot heat yeah so
yeah you turned water into steam and use
that excess pressure to go through a
turbine and then when it says the water
has this dual purpose it you know you
get the power from having turned it into
the steam and you're also cooling the
generator that way okay so okay how did
we figure out that we could collide
atoms and then like understand subatomic
Li or what's going on right well yeah
studying by knowing the radiation coming
out of it yeah and the first experiments
were I mean like literally people moving
clumps of uranium together with their
hands and seeing that it warmed up oh oh
just warm up the clumps of uranium would
warm up because they're trying to what
they're trying to electrons which are
like well that's that's odd yeah
nevermind if they just irradiated
themselves them they're gonna get cancer
but when you don't know what you're
doing and exploring this stuff is yeah
so so you know we the early experiments
are often quite quite risky since you're
exploring the unknown and it was the
Large Hadron Collider built 2011 or
before that well I mean they started
building it far before that but I think
it first turned on I think around 2008
okay yeah okay for first turn-on
and so okay so no and then they're their
largest success was finding the Higgs
boson no yes well verse oh yes didn't
that mess with our parallel universe you
didn't hear anything about that though
no maybe yours I do believe in other
parallel universes in those universes
but not so much in this one
wait you believe in parallel universes
in those universes you're not in this
one yeah the me that's in other
simulated realities believes in the
other simulated realities but the mean
this one ah yeah okay I'm far too
skeptical
[Laughter]
okay and then China has a massive
particle accelerator as well no but they
will though they're building one there
they're talking about building one yeah
it's in early enough stage it has they
haven't committed funding to it yet but
I think they will they just built that
massive satellite radio yeah China's
building some amazing stuff and I think
it's very likely that the the particle
charter that supersedes the Large Hadron
Collider will be in China yeah yeah yeah
yeah come on us wow the US had their
shot I mean we we were gonna build the
superconducting supercollider from Texas
yeah there was gonna be even larger than
they'd like see from the get-go and that
was that was back in the 90s I was
coming together and got funding is you
know gonna happen the thing is is just
too big of a target for Congress to exit
out off the budget cuz that's whatever
10 billion 20 billion yeah there's gonna
be a big price tag yeah but you know I
mean I'm very biased since I'm a
theoretical physicist and I want to know
biased towards science - I'm so biased
toward science the thing is these sorts
of this sort of exploration that you're
doing yeah it doesn't have practical
impact for at least 50 years and most
you know governments tell you want
flying cars we want flying cars well
we're gonna have plenty of flying cars
once we have good batteries so the
batteries are the hold up for flying
cars and what we're gonna have them so
we're gonna have like personal quad
copters and and they're gonna be
fantastic there you going get 20-minute
ride yeah the batteries batteries yeah
okay so so now we are colliding atoms
and now so what so you said we're using
same similar microscopes Pinal it's like
an electron microscopy so it's even okay
so now explain like how you're watching
yeah so if you seem like a scanning
tunneling electron microscope photo they
can get much higher resolution than
light and that's because the the
electrons right have a much shorter
wavelength than light has okay with
light you can get down to two nanometers
for the size of things you can resolve
but with electrons you can didn't see
down even smaller
and with with protons you can see
smaller still because they have smaller
smaller wavelengths and you can put more
and more energy in them and so you don't
have access to see what's on the smaller
scales until you can collide larger more
massive particles with more energy and
that's that's how you see things at
smaller scales and for the for large
there are similar collisions so the
Large Hadron Collider is is colliding
protons very close to the speed of light
and then seeing what is produced from
those collisions and it's pretty great
the way that works and there was you
know someone
I think embarrassingly enough and he was
an attorney from Hawaii from walk over
the Big Island from Miwako and not the
Big Island who started a lawsuit saying
no the LHC might create a black hole
that destroys the earth right by
colliding these protons and energies
higher than they've ever been done
before but the thing is is we have
protons coming in as cosmic rays all the
time and impacting the moon impacting
our atmosphere and it does turn the moon
into a black hole even though it has
higher energy than what the LHC is doing
the problem is you know we don't know
where those collisions are gonna happen
and we want to be able to have the
collision take place in the detector
where we know what the collision
products are and this is this is our
best window now into subatomic particle
physics so with these larger and larger
colliders they always sieving largest
one we're able to see what the
fundamental building blocks are of
atomic nuclei which it turns out are
made out of quarks you know they're made
out of up and down quarks of different
charges and so we now now the same way
we had the LEGO building blocks of atoms
now we have the same building blocks of
subatomic matter of the quarks electrons
neutrinos and the electromagnetic weak
and strong forces holding them together
yeah it's pretty and it's really it
amazingly enough things are really
pretty down there yeah yeah is this a
good time to pull up the EH video sure
yeah sure let's so if you if you plot
out all the charges of the known
elementary particles they make a really
pretty pattern you just plot one
different kind of charge along each axis
all right and then you can you get end
up with a multi-dimensional charge
structure that you can rotate and see
all the pretty patterns in it okay so so
so what we're what we're observing then
is we're observing the quarks neutrinos
charge patterns we're observing that
right now right so this is basically a
diagram so if you take like the
different particles have different
charges so the the up and or down quarks
have charges of one-third and minus
two-thirds and an electron has a
electric charge of minus one right and
you can multiply all those by three it's
just a matter of scaling so they all
have integral charges okay but then the
these particles also have weak charges
all right which is a different kind of
charge than electric charge and then
they also have two different kinds of
strong charge right and they physicists
call this color so there's strong
Chartist weak charges negative charges
positive charge right so there's there's
electric charge there's weak strip we
charge color charge actually is two
orthogonal kinds of charge
there's color charge color charge yeah
and that's that's the name for the
strong force charge okay so the strong
strong force charge takes two two
different kinds of charge to describe
but the end they interact okay but you
also have gravitational spin is another
kind of ya charge right out how these
rotations interact with gravity right
and and they're there you need two
charges for describing gravity okay so
that gets you up to six is percival talk
particle yeah and each particle has some
charge along all six of these axes and
you plot out each particle state but but
is each particle the same six yes but
it's fine each kind of same yeah an
electron has the same charges as any
other electronic cool okay and so you
you plot out about all these axes and
you end up with this diagram in six
dimensional space or higher dimensional
space if you add more charges okay and
then you can project that down to two
dimensions and you see it makes a really
pretty pattern
okay okay so you take the six variables
that you were just discussing and then
you put that on to it to dimension yep
you just flatten it down to two
dimensions and it shows plots like this
and and all this is doing is it's taking
that fixed pattern in higher dimensions
and projecting it down to two different
angles to show different aspects of it
yeah and each one of these points
corresponds to a different kind of
elementary particle yeah okay and and
the since you have charge conservation
these diagrams describe how all these
elementary particles can interact
because the charges have to be conserved
so so the so the purple is an elementary
particle the oranges in how much
particle one corresponds to different
state it's elementary particle this is
all one add no it's not an atom this is
a just one charge diagram this is a
charge diagram for what though for
everything but what do you mean for
every great every known elementary
partner for every yeah but for every
known elementary particle but what's
what are they what are they what are the
orbiting what are they part of what is
that it's part of it appears to be part
of one structure of a structure yes and
we don't and then so this is just
replicated throughout everything right
so it every at every point of space-time
yeah you'd have any collection of any
one of these particles at that point in
space-time so it appears that you know
this thing is can be excited along any
of these particle directions at every
point in space-time and this is why
there's a particle there okay so so now
we go from this is a sea of atoms to now
this is a sea of elementary particles
and and many of these particles will
cluster together and form atoms aha so
so an atom is basically a bunch of up
and down quarks and it more or less you
know one close location okay being
excited and itself interacting with a
bunch of gluons which are the the force
particles of the strong force okay and
that that holds everything together with
with electrons and cloud around them Oh
more or less one spot so it's a bunch of
it's a bunch of these particles getting
excited all in
location and then that happens
everywhere at every point in space-time
and the interaction of this whole swarm
no metric particles gives us the
universe we see how do elementary
particles figure out to come together
with the gluons to make a oxygen or to
make a nitrogen or it has to do with
with how the other particles interact
with them so once you once you know a
particle has a charge alright and what
its charges are against all the four all
these different kinds of charge then you
know how it can interact with the other
particles because it can have any
interactions with any other particles as
long as the charges are conserved when
when they have that interaction so you
can just basically add the charges and
see if that's another particle and if it
is that's a possible interaction and
every possible interaction happens okay
so all these possible interactions are
happening and allowed by charge
conservation so everything happens and
you know and also energy and momentum
conservation and all those interactions
happen and as far as we can tell quantum
mechanics describes you know every
possible interaction happening yeah
so we're we're sort of living living in
this branching out of all quantum
possibilities of all elementary particle
interactions yeah and then now we're
trying to identify the elementary
particle interactions yes so we're
trying to we're trying to fill out the
pattern fill out the pattern yeah so
mathematical physicists figured out that
this pattern actually isn't just a
collection of dots in a diagram you can
actually describe this using geometric
like continuous geometric manifolds
continuous surfaces okay so now we have
legged metaphor board no no I could
checkerboard more like more like things
like circles and twists and knots of
geometry but it's a continuous pattern
though it's it's a continuous geometry
that ends up being described by these
patterns continues geometry described by
this pattern yeah so we know and and
this is important because we know that
space-time itself was like a smooth
four-dimensional fabric that's that's
wavy
okay and and since we know space-time is
accelerating in its expansion as we look
out into the cosmos okay we know that
space-time itself is sort of like a
four-dimensional hyperboloid all right
it's opening up it's accelerating in its
expansion yeah we're all the galaxies
are all moving away from each other so
how in the world does that relate to
these particles ooming around well it
turns out anything to do with dark
energy though it does yeah yeah that's
right
so it's dark energy that exists and
allows the acceleration of expansion of
space so it turns out that all these
particles that were described in this
diagram these correspond to a smooth
shape and when you include the
gravitational description in terms of
how to describe the the gravitational
charges in terms of this smooth shape
you see that the only consistent way to
do it is with this infinite extent
geometric pattern that includes this
hyperbola inside it so this this pattern
corresponds to this wonderfully complex
smooth high dimensional geometric
structure that is described by this
pattern of charges but it's actually the
geometry of this structure itself that's
that's really fundamental and I think
although people go back and forth on
whether when you have it a successful
mathematical abstraction that seems to
match up with reality yeah
how much reality - do you ascribe to
that geometry itself - the geometric
structure and I think our our universe
is this mathematical structure that's
come to life and and although that
sounds wild I mean in for the most part
using these sorts of geometries to
describe elementary particle physics
this is standard particle physics
okay these these geometries called Li
groups and the the way it's grabbing
them and their curvature over space-time
as gauge Theory has been known to
mathematical physicists since the 50s so
this is the the the fundamental way of
the universe yeah yeah the universe is
fundamentally geometry fundamentally
geometry just geometric this map
this this math and geometry that's going
on replicating itself throughout the
fabric that's right and it's doing it in
a quantum mechanical way such as
exploring all possible paths at once
that that's our best understanding of it
to known physics and what I do is a
little a little more unusual which is
this structure and this description of
reality seems sufficiently coherent
there and it all appears to be part of
just one mathematical structure which
which to me is very compelling yeah so I
found this match up in 2008 or 2007 I
guess late 2007 between the known
structure of elementary particle charges
and their interactions and this one
mathematical structure called the e8 Li
group and and this is sufficiently
inspiring that I have worked on this for
a number of years and and more recently
I've been trying to come together with a
natural quantum mechanical description
of the theory which was which is which
has been pretty wild itself because
because what nobody has done is come up
with even though we've described
everything in terms of geometry in terms
of smooth structures quantum mechanics
is always something that sort of added
as a as something put in by hand to take
a classical theory in a classical
geometry and then apply the quantization
procedure and get a quantum description
that's something that's always done by
hand but the universe can't work that
way
the universe is fundamentally quantum
mechanical so if there is a fundamental
structure that describes the universe it
has to be a quantum geometrical
structure and that's that's what I've
been after lately well well as if things
weren't complicated enough so when
you're when you're considering the
geometry geometry that describes this
pattern it's a you know you end up with
a 248 dimensional twisted up structure
but quantum mechanically right each one
of these points in this structure
corresponds to just one particle
all right but when you do quantum field
theory you can have multiple particles
of the same kind at any space-time point
oh jeez alright so if you're gonna have
a geometry that describes that in a
consistent way quantum mechanically you
have to have an arbitrarily number of
these particles at every point yeah so
you don't have even though 248 was a
ridiculously high number of dimensions
and high number of particles in order to
consistently have a quantum I have a
description of quantum field theory that
matches reality you have to have an
infinite dimensional geometric structure
and when you have multiple particles at
a points that's different levels of the
structure being excited at that point
but it turns out mathematicians have
expanded on these these finite
dimensional lis groups and they have
explored infinite dimensionally groups
and their representations and that's
this is much more recent research you
know or in the starting in the 80s or
90s okay and there's that there's
actually a professor here at Berkeley
who's pioneered the use of these
description of these specific infinite
naturally groups that I think best apply
describing quantum geometry infinite
dimensional lis groups yeah describing
quantum geometry yeah I think that's
what I think that's what the universe is
but this is this is new stuff I've been
exploring and it just looks extremely
promising but yeah I think this is
fundamentally what our universe is is
it's one of these beautiful infant
dimensionally groups undergoing
excitations
everything we see is the result yeah and
but and the the thing that gets me about
this is sort of the inevitability of
this being our universe because when you
look at these mathematical structures
you you don't have I mean you you can
sort of dismiss some of the simplest one
that wouldn't give you rich enough
behavior but if you pick out the richest
ones with the the most complex structure
you end up with you know a very small
selection of possible realities that we
could
being and that just that just comes from
pure mathematics if there's some alien
race and some other galaxies in the
observable universe that's that's worked
out high-energy physics and mathematics
they're gonna they're gonna see these
same mathematical structures any
advanced alien civilization is gonna
know about the groups just purely from
abstract mathematics yeah it just comes
out of pure math as in the fabric of the
universe is like this across the
universe not only from our astronomical
observations we we can tell that the
universe is homogeneous the things
appear to be the same at far distances
the same laws of physics from how seeing
how stars and galaxies behave it huge
distances not only that but just
abstract mathematics itself when you you
know start with the integers and then
you know the real numbers and then
abstractly describe smooth services work
and smooth services to how can they tie
into little knots when you go on that
path you hit this description of lis
groups and things that are special about
lis groups and they have all sorts of
unusual characteristics that you
wouldn't guess but any civilization
working out this mathematics it's going
to hit them it's gonna know about what
happens when we tap into the quantum
geometry into the understanding of the
lis groups to its fullest for in terms
of practical applications yeah I have no
idea how that's gonna go
I I don't have any more idea of passing
ago than the first people to start
thinking about atoms existing yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah it's it's first you have
to find it figure out what it is and
then it takes you know 50 100 years of
engineering before you can manipulate
things on that scale yeah and and then
make use of it yeah maybe that maybe
that has a tie-in to nanotechnology I
would be beyond nanotechnology it'd be
beyond nano but maybe that could then
help with nanotech to be able to just
make just to roll up a little sphere and
have it turn into a car and then I can't
even speculate what can what's gonna
happen you are gonna need large amounts
of energy to manipulate things on it on
a tiny scale of that level
you're gonna have to like use stars and
pull them together to create black holes
and you know use arrangements of black
holes to create sufficient to manipulate
particle beams in such a way to
manipulate things on that scale because
you need enormous energies to get down
and access and tinker with things on
that scale can't fusion provide that
well that's it might
essentially that's what a star is it's a
young fusing massive matter yes yes so
in some degree yes but the thing is is
in the same way that you know the first
atomic bombs were made by taking
fissionable material like uranium or
plutonium and surrounding it with
basically dynamite and compressing it
inward with the explosion of the
dynamite to kick off the fusion bomb
it's the same thing you sort of lever up
in energy so who knows what will we have
to do to create the power to manipulate
things on the tiny scale but it's it's
so many it's centuries away from us but
I'm not driven by practical application
I'm driven by wanting to understand what
the universe the discovery yeah the
discovery I'm kind of I'm driven by both
the discovery in the practical
application yeah how many times have you
looked at this and cried it was a it
wasn't sad when I first saw this thing
it was more like an orgasm that's why I
like cry when I see things I'm learning
too much about you I know now is such a
it was a very exciting moment just to
see that this short these structures
underlying particle physics are actually
this pretty yeah right you don't expect
me I was playing with matrices of
variables interacting with one another
through linear algebra and to go from
those matrices to find out that oh
there's all this beautiful structure
behind it and actually see a visual
representation of this pretty structure
and to see all the interconnections
between everything appearing these
amazing mathematical structures yeah
that was that was mind-blowing
I had to like I did you know take a
moment till I was until the excitement
and ward down enough they could go back
to working on
yeah yeah exactly so looking at this
with me for a minute one of these
elementary particles is the Higgs boson
and then yeah it's where ones are the
higgs pigs okay cool so so now if you
end up back in the larger pattern you
can see how they interact with all the
particles to give them their masses
Ronnie will you pull back up control of
that what's right yeah so if you just or
if you freeze it uh-huh okay yeah so if
you so if you if you pick one of these
Higgs bosons uh-huh
you can see like if you if you add this
alright so if you take this distance
from the center to this Higgs here yeah
you can you can add that to this one to
get that one oh so this distance is yeah
so you you you take this as a vector and
you add it I mean and you get that yeah
so that's this is the the Higgs
interacting with this quark to give that
quark so the charges all have to
conserve so it's just vector addition we
need you to the charge the charge
conservation so when they all overlap
like when we see them like come together
and then go back out when that happens
that's the super positioning of the
particle no it's just the artifact of
the projection there's an artifact of
the projection right because it's not a
tuma but when you do the vector vector
addition so if you because you said it
was 248 yeah well but this diagram is
only eight dimensions so when you but if
things have to satisfy charge
conservation along all eight dimensions
okay so the so you take a vector from
here to there right this is a vector and
and you add it and you get the same
vector between these two particles yes
okay when you take that and you project
it down to two dimensions you'll end up
with a two dimensional vector but and
that'll still equal the other vectors
yeah the projection conserves the charge
conservation it preserves it yeah that's
why you see it as the the same lengths
on here yeah so you can actually look at
this two dimensional diagram and see all
the allowed interactions which is pretty
cool
and but it's it's it's a it's really I
found it to be a really enlightening way
to describe elementary particle
interactions yep there's some things
that are harder to capture so we know
that all these particles have different
masses and these masses aren't charged
okay the the masses aren't quantized
they're not they don't behave as charged
so it has to be those masses have to be
coming out with some from some other
aspect of geometry mm-hmm which nobody
knows I described yet they all weigh
different amounts yeah
and we're talking like on the scale of
well the I mean so for every every known
elementary particle like an electron it
has to more massive partners so called
the second and third generations so an
electron has a the muon and the Tau and
these are other elementary particles
that appear to have the same charges the
same electric weak in strong charges but
they have different masses and nobody
knows why that happens
so what has to be happening is since the
the Higgs particle is interacting with
these to give them their mass it has to
interact with these other particles in a
different way to give them different
masses and the masses are order are like
they're off by a factor of 100 they
differ by a factor of 100 so as as soon
as these more massive particles are
created like the Italians created it's
instantly gone and it changes into less
massive particles okay so a Tau will
immediately decay down to MU and kick
off a neutrino and antineutrino
and then from an emu down to an electron
so there is a tendency for them for this
elementary particles to move based on
the weight of them yeah it's it's their
their masses dictate what can decay into
what what can change in the way but we
don't we don't know we don't have a good
description right now in physics of why
they have their four masses it's a big
mystery so the elementary particles are
also decaying and yeah they're changing
one into the other all the time even in
the sphere every every interaction is a
particle changing into another two
particles every inner working
whose every other every interaction yeah
these particles coming together to make
a different part of a different particle
and a neutrino that is another kind of
particle yeah yes it's so interesting as
there's a when we when we sat down with
them with clear when as well there's
never been a time that I felt and the
same thing goes for you more like a
explain like I'm five on this on the
shows about about physics and in Florida
five love Legos so you know elementary
particles appear to be the Legos of our
universe yeah yeah and they each have
different their charges correspond to
their their you know their the Lego
shaped you know how many pips it has and
what it what other Legos you can attach
to because not all elementary particles
can a can attach to other or no they
have to be competin they have to have
compatible charging paddle charges and
those other variables there were like
five of the other variables they're all
charges alright thank you Ron all right
so let's alright let's talk about psi a
bit as well I want to show some of the
other beauty this is amazing I would
have I I you know whenever my mind gets
expanded to new dimensions of thought I
freaking cry I cry and I like I feel
this just insane
ethereal feeling I can't even be you
know described but let's um let's talk
so so psi and I'm excited to show some
of the some of the content that we have
lined up here what would be a good let's
start with maybe the drone the drone
shot of sure yeah well I mean I came up
with these physics ideas in 2008 and at
the same time I was supporting myself by
investing and I and I had been traveling
around through different friends houses
while I was doing the work and what I
found is it's really easy to work on
stuff while you're living in friends
yeah yeah exactly because you're not
worried about having to fix stuff you're
not you're not living in your to do list
yes the way you are if you own a house
yes and you're thinking about all the
stuff you need to do you need to do so I
was able in my relaxed you've been
working high to be able to do the
research and you know so I've been
traveling around for a decade since
getting my PhD basically living in
friends houses well I'm doing I'm doing
this work in physics or renting places
and investing my money as best as I
could but after a decade of this I
wanted to make it a resource available
to other scientists yep I wanted I
wanted other scientists to have the
ability to go to some nice place and
just hang out there and not be told what
to do but to work on what they wanted to
work on yep well they stayed somewhere
beautiful and so I got the money
together and and you know God half a
million dollars put down on a decent
little ranch house in Hawaii a friend of
mine helped me build some little cabins
and and so now we've got a few bedroom
bedroom cabins and this fairly modest
property in Maui it's its location this
is gonna show us the the cabin shot now
yeah on the way down
yes on Maui about 20 minutes out from
the beach driving your friend came and
helped you put these together these
cabins there's four of these cabins and
they're right on the same property and
you had you were inspired by your kind
of like your freedom you had freedom
with your time too and you wanted to
provide that with other people yeah
so it's a it's a great little
environment I mean people come out and
hang out anywhere from a couple days to
months and it's a nice little scientific
community on Maui we also you know go on
trips to the beach surfing kite surfing
paragliding lots of fun stuff to do
around the island we have that video of
kite foiling yeah let's do it let's
let's showcase that that video because
that's also excited yeah now is it it's
just a beautiful place to I mean I yeah
this is gorgeous this is this is this is
earth you know
earth this is the beauty of Earth this
20 minutes away yeah yeah so so
basically I wanted to I mean science has
given us a chore you wanted to give us
also the ability to tie right into
nature right here in Hawaii at the same
time as you're doing the science yeah
and scientists is science have given us
the the best tools and the best progress
mankind has has achieved and it's really
due to scientists working on this stuff
and they're not always compensated as
much as they should be given how much
they're benefiting humanity so as a
personal philanthropy I feel that were
the best things I can do is try to make
life better for scientists and the best
way I've found to do that is give a nice
place to stay and work without any
stress and you know hopefully will come
up with more good stuff yeah yeah it's
also really fun for me is on a personal
level it's it's very satisfying to be
able to have a bunch of smart people
coming through yeah exactly and this is
this is some of the more fun I've been
having lately is hydrofoil a with a kite
oh man look how fast you're going
because you're not writing any waves
yeah there's very little resistance of
it it's a very efficient craft and
you're just using the kite to pull you
know you're zipping along the water
you're and you leave almost no wake
because you're not smacking the water
exactly flying through the carbon fiber
wing yep wicked off that carbon fiber
wing yeah you're just standing on top of
the board the wing goes down into the
water and then yeah that's such that was
such a smart invention yeah if someone
described it to me I would have said
there's no way that is gonna work it's
gonna be too unstable and it is unstable
but it's this it's manageably stable it
must be very very unstable yeah it
doesn't want you balancing on it no yeah
but without it that opposing force of
the kite
acting as a sail and then with the foil
acting against it yes just stable enough
yeah yeah and you're going what like
you're only what 20 mile yeah yeah
that's 20 20 or 30 knots
I mean this is the life in life yeah
it's the life you're a smart man for
wanting to you know build it on one of
the most beautiful on places in the
world and yeah and and also provide
people like you said with that time with
that ability to come in and and and
really just be able to focus on what
they want to do and relax at the same
time the major I think it actually
produces more effective results when
you're able to go to the beach 20
minutes away from you it's it's
wonderful just for for clearing your
mind and I think there's there's just to
be able to focus your eyes on beautiful
scenery yeah 20 miles away yes I think
that's not only good for our vision it's
very good for vision right but it also
is good for our souls for the soul as
well yes to actually just you know be in
the ocean and be smelling fresh oxygen
and hailing and fresh oxygen now let's
pull up the other you have a hangar now
hang gliding paragliding right yeah Maui
Maui is basically a playground in
Paradise I mean it's just spectacularly
beautiful and you can Wow choose to go
out and do something fun every day if
you want to what is that those are the
West Maui mountains so so right now I'm
standing on Haleakala which is a 10,000
foot yeah yeah and this is a view from
about 6,000 feet and then the Maui is
basically a big valley between that
mountain and the West Maui mountains
which are about 5,000 feet so pretty
much you're seeing pretty much the whole
island right here this is just an unreal
video look at all those closet is
perfectly right it is such a ridiculous
place Wow yeah so lucky that and this is
one of the most consistent paragliding
launch sites in the in the world it's
you can do this pretty much every
morning and it's a 20-minute drive up
psi yeah it's a consistent looks amazing
so you bring a parachute with
yes thank you a paraglider fits into a
backpack yeah okay yeah but then you all
see you're wearing a parachute oh yeah
yeah you have a reserve you know cars
are shoot yeah and then but you're
usually you're usually too loaded to
play how do you how do you get to like
you drive up know about how do you get
Heidi Heidi how do you get to ensure
that you like stay up above the tree
line and not like go down you start with
a steep enough slope you fly out away
from the slope yeah and then the idea is
if the if the Sun is heated up the earth
enough it'll kick off updrafts and so
you you fly into these thermals and you
have a very amador that tells you
whether you're going up and down so you
hit a thermal and then you start going
up yeah and if you hit one yep and then
you start spiraling in it and ride it up
yeah yeah and then you can go over
it--and yeah and then you get higher and
then it Peters out and then you go
looking for the next one and as you're
looking for the next one you're dropping
but then you find another one ride that
one up this was really great footage of
all these oh thanks yeah I remember that
way Mike didn't quite get my head in
tight enough tight enough on the hood
yeah look at how it looks from the
bottom as well you're riding what was
that like a 10-foot wave a little
smaller than the eight yeah yeah I mean
Hawaiian would call that a three-foot
wave really would call it
okay so we'll have links for psi in the
bio you go stop by and go hang out
Garrett definitely have to go hang out
with Garrett we'll be there do you guys
help us out on patreon we will go there
and interview the brilliant scientists
there and we will get our butts there
much faster and we'll be able to produce
better content for you and work on
creativity work on so really for the
betterment of mankind send Alan to Maui
out there and so it's okay so that's psi
now I want to ask you a couple questions
that we typically ask on the show the
first question being there
there seems to be a lot of of wealth
that's being concentrated in the hands
of very few and then the that's being
exacerbated by exponential technology
and then the very lowest of
socioeconomic classes are going up just
very slightly um what do you think about
that I think that it's a it's a struggle
and a lot of the infrastructure and
social systems that are in place are
there to enforce that they're there to
make sure that the poor stay poor and
that they don't grab resources away from
the rich so we're always sort of so the
wealthy sort of play this game where
they they're trying to concentrate and
grow and maintain their wealth and if
too many people climb up to their level
that often takes away from them chisels
away at it so they try to make it the
game so it's very hard to do that yeah
whereas technological progress sort of
floats every boat all right so as
technology progresses that that does
increase quality of life for everybody
on the planet okay so as long as you're
not worried so much about people having
it better than you then your life's
getting better yeah more than likely but
economically just the way capitalism
works wealth is able to accumulate and
grow more wealth so capitalism a is
always sort of at risk of being too
harsh on the less well-off and if you're
really too harsh on people who have it
bad they're gonna rebel they're gonna
pick up guns pitchforks bats whatever
and just wreak hell I'm your your
property and on your life so the wealthy
always playing this game it's like well
we don't want to be too bad on them
because then they'll Rebell and and our
quality of life will be bad but I think
I think it needs to be better than that
because I don't want to live in an
environment where people are peeing on
the streets right I don't want to live
an environment where there are sick
people wandering around that need help
and aren't getting it yep
personally even if it cost me money I'd
rather live in a society that takes care
of its poor and so that the my
environment is bad
purely for selfish reasons purely for
selfish reasons I don't want a bunch of
people being poor I want everybody to
have you know health care available to
them who needs it I'd like everybody to
have at least a subsistence amount of
food and shelter provided to them
at the bare minimum yeah yeah and and as
we have more and more technological
increase especially with with computers
being able to do more fewer there can be
fewer need for the labor of humans yep
and there so there will be more and more
people who can't get jobs and just for
purely you know inevitable reasons I
think we're gonna have some something
like a universal basic income for people
and keep in mind I'm mostly a
libertarian I just want the world to be
as good as possible so I can enjoy
living in it but that means making life
do you sin for everybody we were just
talking about this at the blockchain
economic forum yesterday there are
interviews that there's never gonna be a
ceiling we never want to put a ceiling
up for wealth accruing wealth but a very
bare minimum how we do that
funneling money down you want to teach
people to fish right so you want to give
them access to these information
highways that enable them to be up at
this bear level every child being born
into the world having access to all this
opportunity at least how do we balance
the we are one mentality with
geopolitical leadership we have to
cannot go backwards so there there is a
pull to go backwards a and we just saw
it in this last election I mean the
election of Trump was a step backwards I
mean we were heading towards more
progressive being more progressive
nation where we're getting along better
with other nations we were providing
more for the for the less fortunate in
our country we're providing more for the
middle class but the the middle class
and lower class decided to take the step
backwards where they wanted like a like
a stronger more egomaniacal
a conservative leader in place who was
gonna make who they thought was gonna
make our interests better make us
interest better at the expense of our
foreign neighbors and
apparently at the expense of everything
except the corporations and the people
who own them so I think Trump is a great
president if you're a large shareholder
running companies even great if you're
doing a bunch of scientific development
and in the medical field because he's
big about deregulation but if you're
poor and need medical care it sucks so I
think what I've been saying is Trump is
great for corporations and lousy for
people but I think we're gonna see the
pendulum swing back and I hope it
doesn't swing back too much that it
hurts corporations so much because uh
because I do think it's capitalism
that's driving progress in our society
for a large degree and I don't want to
slow it down definitely do you think
that we are alone in the cosmos if you
mean are we alone and that there's
nobody else out there sentient beings
like us no I think there the universe is
so vast and life so ubiquitous I think
there's you know many many other
advanced civilizations out there in the
universe if you mean do I think we're
alone and then nobody is talking to us
yeah I think we're alone that way I
don't think I don't think there's been
any contact between any alien
civilizations and an earth what do you
think is roaming throughout these
galaxies who knows what's out there I
mean space is not very hospitable to
meat so I think what most likely happens
is some civilization reaches an advanced
enough to degree to make cool
intelligent things out of metal and
launch them into space so I think lots
of probes go out that are basically
synthetic intelligence with with metal
metal bodies and they go out and explore
and colonize and communicate and it
becomes largely a spacefaring if you
want to call it a you know synthetic
intelligent automated civilization
hopefully you can just put consciousness
onto those probes at a suitable level of
Technology you'll be able to upload
consciousness into
whatever knowledge one because teleport
right into the other world area it's
gonna be a party I'm almost it almost
makes me regret being born this early
uh-huh right because because I think the
future is gonna be pretty fantastic and
what humans are hippler do yeah I also I
have to I have to admit I'm a little bit
resentful that I feel like I'm gonna die
right before we have really effective
longevity what life extension yeah yeah
because there's a lot of progress being
made right now and a lot of research now
just starting to get supported yes in
extending not only quality of life but
also duration of life yes and I think
that's gonna be a revolution in our
society
and I think it's great but the torch of
psi I think I'm gonna miss it I kind of
I'm kind of I'm gonna be sad not to be
there
Oh Kerry great well you'll be rebirthed
into you've done a lot of great work so
into something even better who knows
yeah but I this is Woody Allen quote I
don't want to live on if you my work I'd
rather be known for living on in my
apartment okay and then how about do you
think there's a designer to the universe
no I don't think there needs to be I
mean as far as as far as I can tell this
universe is some pretty mathematics
that's come to life and there's there's
nothing about it that if you're gonna
design a universe you're gonna make one
that looks more like Conway's Game of
Life right where it's a checkerboard you
have teams in rocky on the checkerboard
and progressing you get complex
structures there and and you can get
very complex interacting systems with
some very simple discrete classical
rules and our universe is nothing like
that okay our universe is a wonderfully
complex mathematical structure and it's
evolving quantum mechanically and Cuong
mechanically it has an infinite number
of degrees of freedom even if space
itself was discretized even if was a
checkerboard which it's probably not
okay you would still have an infinite
number of degrees of freedom and
infinite probability variations for how
everything is evolving so if you're
going to design and
universe to be simulated on a computer
you wouldn't design this one right you
you'd have a universe that was much
simpler to simulate if this is a
simulated reality it's a reality being
simulated for some purpose that that is
simulating reality sort of like the one
that's doing the simulating so we can
analyze the progress and see how it does
except except there's been no indication
of any influence by whatever might be
simulating this reality truth so so
given that that's the case
effectively from a scientific viewpoint
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter if there's a
simulation or not maybe it is maybe it
isn't also I mean there's a
probabilistic argument for why this is a
simulation but this might we might be in
a simulated reality because a
sufficiently advanced civilization can
simulate realities and we expect there
to be many advanced civilizations in the
universe doing many simulations so given
that there's only one universe and many
simulations it's more likely
probabilistic Lee that you're in a
simulation that's a fairly compelling
argument however we only have one case
to go on we only have the one data point
we could be in a very unusual situation
and since we only have the one bit of
data good to go on you gets you can't
really make reasonable statements about
probabilistic distributions when you
only have one data point and our last
question is what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world oh
it's hard to beat a really beautiful
breaking wave when you're in it but it's
just such an amazing experience I really
don't know anything better than that
there it is again
yeah when you're doing that there it
doesn't get much better than that it'll
make you make you mortgage your house
sell your stuff and just spend
ridiculous amounts of money on fancy
surf trips yeah love it's so beautiful
it is riding the waves of the earth I've
also said that you know writing down the
the slopes of the earth for skiers oh
yes kind of stuff paragliding
paragliding again just yeah there was
some of my favorite moments was after
you skydive then you're just sitting
there in your chair just gliding through
yeah paragliding if you like that part
you'd like paragliding that's all that
part it's all that part if you're doing
the other part the freefall part while
you're paragliding that's bad yeah what
a thought-provoking show thank you so
much for coming Gary we appreciate it so
much
yeah this was so enriching I feel like I
understand elementary particles point
zero zero zero zero one percent I feel
like I you know at least there's that
okay great well there was a lot of good
wisdom here communicated a few guys had
a good time make sure to share what you
learned with two people they'll go share
what they learned with two people so
keep doing that
join us subscribe comment below with
your thoughts don't just consume this
content go create with it make a video
make a post go talk to your mom and your
Papa your uncle your sister your cousins
go talk to them all about it also join
us on patreon sir and continue doing
cool things like this increasing our
studio space making better content for
you more live events going to the
Pacific scientists to highlighting smart
people out there much love everyone
thanks for tuning in thanks for on our
producing partner and we'll talk to you
soon
you
you